the world is an extremely complicated
place trying to make sense of it more
often than not leads to confusion and
the acceptance of our own limitations
that is not necessarily a bad thing
understanding your limitations can make
you intellectually humble in that state
you're more open to alternative
approaches and more prone to the
adoption of more creative methodologies
notorious investor Charlie Munger
famously said and so just as a man
working with a tool has to know its
limitations a man working with his
cognitive apparatus has to also know its
limitations
your biggest weapon is self-awareness
and that includes understanding every
constituent of yourself hood strengths
and weaknesses especially weaknesses
especially if you're young and your
identity still crude ten years ago when
I was in my early twenties my main
concern was how to escape the
incompetence associated with my being
young and inexperienced then years later
I'm here creating this video having
moved from crudeness to refinement and
attempting to creatively elucidate the
worldly wisdom I managed to attain that
process wasn't invariant but rather
quite multifaceted it entailed the
employment of various models especially
mental models I ways to enhance your
repertoire of cognitive skills in order
to make more intelligence and sagacious
decisions mental models form something
like a neural lattice work that is a
mental construction that can allow ideas
to interlace and merge in order to offer
the best solution when complex problems
arise you can think of a mental model as
a heuristic that utilizes memory in
intuition in a very special and
effective way the mental models are many
some are considered common knowledge and
some quite sophisticated and specific
the vastness of the latticework a
produce makes it intimidating for one to
even decide to deal with them in the
first place this video is an atom from
my side to make this process easier and
offer a primer to the five mental models
I considered most interesting but also
most universal I hope that after
grasping the concepts you will take the
time and effort required to explore them
even further and eventually internalize
them
there is this great book by British
American author simon Sinek called start
with why it's premise is that leaders
who want to inspire action need to make
sure that their message is communicated
in a precise and well articulated manner
when they want to move forward and share
their vision and the fundamental element
of their message should be the why in
essence the power of why lies in the
fact that it can evoke a series of
questions that will allow a person to
bring more awareness to their experience
and eventually reinforce their sense of
inner purpose the why is the predecessor
of justification with the right
justification or reasoning becomes
crystallized we no longer operate in an
abstract an aimless fashion we are ready
to take action the power of why so
potent and its applicability is so
Universal that it can eventually morph
into a mental model people have been
using the power of Y since the ancient
times to inspire action taking and to
energize crowds in fact the Y model is
also a great tool when it comes to
determining personal meaning for
instance psychotherapists usually try to
help people escape their inner struggles
by attempting to raise awareness via the
why model the client can enter the
discovery plane go back in time face
silencing events and associate them with
current behavioral patterns this
association gives rise to wine and
eventually the person can work towards
the how even Petrovich Pavlov was a
Russian psychologist known for his work
on classical conditioning classical
conditioning is a buzzword that refers
to the procedure during with a
biological stimulus like food when
paired with a neutral stimulus like a
bell can form a learning process during
this process the subject in Pavlov's
case a dog when it makes the association
it manages to elicit the same response
during the neutral stimulus as it would
during the biological stimulus Pavlov's
dog when it encountered food started to
salivate after the association took
place it started to salivate just by
listening to the sound of the Bell the
significance of this discovery is
monumental because we realize that it is
an enormous leap powerful psychological
force in
daily life of all of us Pavlovian
association is used consciously and
unconsciously by various agents in the
domain of marketing and general
influence strategy when coca-cola for
instance decides that it wants to be
associated with great events like the
Olympics and employee alluring images in
their ads you can't help but associate
coca-cola with something beautiful and
enjoyable when Trump decided to
reutilize the slogan make America great
again he seeks to create an association
with past glories and through gal full
romanticism to evoke feelings of
nostalgia for the good old days the
power of Pavlovian association lies in
this effect most of the work is done at
the subconscious level and our attempt
to escape it is oftentimes fruitless I
consider Pavlovian Association a great
mental model for both self-awareness and
influence purposes making sense of when
we act or react based on mere
Association is a great way to understand
conceal the aspects of our personality
furthermore making sense of when other
people act or react based on mere
Association can work wonders in our
effort to influence them in the
classroom in shows we do not do a lot
with denominator anything volunteer or
function a significant issue but not the
content ideas okay who else it times its
exact still exist cause no pattern no no
what some stylish new V&A associated
open the Google income you know them to
be on infamy Michel Foucault focused
most of his work on power and authority
and understood clearly that power can
play significant role in the way people
or entities influence the fabric of
society in my opinion our overall
approach towards authority can never be
fully functional
however the eminent rise in awareness
over the last decades around the topic
does pretend the tidal shift towards its
proper evaluation bias from over
influence by authorities fostered from a
young
and as long as the individuals I render
so to speak to authoritarian figures the
bias will remain Authority create
security but the security is nothing
more than a substitute for emotional
attachment which in turn inhibits the
ability of the individual to cultivate
self ownership bias by world is not
necessarily a bad thing but the calculus
to get malevolent acts if individuals
don't recognize its effect on their
decision-making as a contrarian I'm not
here to suggest only politically correct
approach to daunting issues I understand
that concepts like Authority constitute
a gray area and our moral landscape most
probably we will never be able to escape
it so many presents this is the reason I
present it as a mental model becoming
aware of its ubiquitous nature can offer
a way to deal with power and authority
in the most human way possible the word
entropy from Greek and ropm a turning
toe word was invented by German
physicist Rudolf Clausius in 1865 and
his attempt to measure the level of
disorder within a system Claudius was
referring to a thermodynamic system but
since then the word has been popularized
in order to explain the change in
randomness in any system essentially
when entropy is high randomness is high
within a system and vice-versa in
colloquial language when people discuss
entropy
they generally attempt to paint a
picture of our chaotic world the realm
of cosmos as it is interpreted by the
human mind is a mishmash of information
that needs to be processed the more
complexity we bring to the table the
more we increase entropy our attempt to
control the situation on a macro level
is futile entropy will keep increasing
over time and our ability to deal with
this increase becomes a bizarre and
far-fetched dream the Stoics have
observed this phenomenon hundreds of
years ago and their philosophy was
proposed as a strong antidote focusing
on things you can control and ignoring
the rest is the most compelling argument
in our attempt to control entropy at
least on a micro level Steven Pinker has
famously said that the ultimate purpose
of life mind and human striving is to
deploy energy and information to fight
back the
Devendra pian carve out the refuges of
beneficial order this mental model
becomes more and more vital as we age
and we realize that our survival and
flourishing is located on the nexus
between discipline conscientiousness and
planning German mathematician Carl
Gustav yaqoob' famously said man muslima
UN Karen
meaning one needs to always invert
inversion is essentially the ability of
working backwards looking at a result
and trying to guide oneself to the
initial concept is a powerful mental
model of many for two reasons number one
thinking backwards is oftentimes more
helpful in deconstructing the problem
than thinking forwards and number two
pondering the ultimate consequences of a
specific course of action can eventually
make you more grounded and calm the
simplest way to understand this and this
is the thing that usually instead of
aiming towards abstract happiness it is
better to ensure that we will minimize
misery a reason for instance that I
admire Elon Musk is because of his
pragmatism
most people get starstruck by his
boldness and audacity but few really
recognize that the substrate that
fosters boldness and audacity is
actually pragmatism when you accept the
chance of your success even if those
chances are let's say 10% you position
yourself in a more grounded and serene
place subsequently when you try to
carefully identify the parameters that
may increase the chances of success and
reduce the chances of failure your
ability to deal with them becomes more
manageable and your desperation morphs
into competence and confidence I hope
that this video worked as a great primer
to mental models and what they represent
there are many more mental models to be
covered and discovered and I seriously
hold the belief that an evolved mind
needs to familiarize itself with as many
as possible driven by our insatiable
hunger for self transcendence we become
overwhelmed by the vastness of stimuli
that bombards our somewhat limited
cognition we aim for coherence but we
get lost in abstraction a mental model
is essential
secur pathway from abstraction to
coherence hey guys hope you enjoyed
today's video if you did make sure to
LIKE subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below something cool please so
that more people can discover it if you
want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrián out